I certainly hope it unites us because it
is not a solution isn't going to come
for any one country if the United States
were to adopt Keota tomorrow and China
and India where to continue not to be
partners in it we're not going to solve
the problem so it's going to take all of
us but it's very hard to ask other
countries to do what you're not willing
to do so that's why I believe it's
important that we do have a permanent
and a hard cap on carbon we need to do
that we need to move in that direction
and it is a way that we can unite but
we're going to have other environmental
challenges and another one that should
unite the world is water quantity and
quality and of course climate change
effects that and that is a very real
impact on people today